Ladies and gentlemen, let's be honest about something. Most of us, we see wrongdoing out in the world, somebody breaking the law out in the open flagrantly, most of us do nothing. No matter how many movies we've seen with the big lesson is that it only takes one plucky, courageous person to make a stand, we've got stuff to do. People are expecting us. We don't go to the trouble, even if it would be so easy, if the crime that we're witnessing is minor and non-violent and sort of outrageous.
各位，咱们坦诚一点吧。我们大多数人看到世间的不法行为，看到有人在大庭广众之下明目张胆地违法，大多数人什么都不会做。无论我们看过多少电影，里面传达的大道理都是“只需要一个勇敢、果敢的人站出来”，但我们自己还有事要忙。人们还在等我们。我们不会自找麻烦，即便这很容易，即便我们目睹的罪行只是轻微的、非暴力的，而且有些令人愤慨。
So, here's a good one. I'm going to get off the bike for this one.
那么，这里有个好例子。我要为这个例子下车了。
Well, please meet Gersh Kuntzman, a guy in his 50s, gray beard, quick with a friendly smile. We're riding bikes around Lower Manhattan, looking for illegal license plates.
来，见见格什·昆茨曼（Gersh Kuntzman），一位50多岁的人，留着灰胡子，笑容随和。我们正骑着自行车在曼哈顿下城转悠，寻找违法的车牌。
What mostly happens is, I'll be biking along, and when you've looked at literally thousands of plates, you can see right out of the corner of your eye if something's wrong. Often, even just a fake plate will have a different glint in the sun. In this guy's case, I could see it's a covered plate.
通常的情况是，我骑车经过时，因为你已经看过成千上万个车牌，只要一眼就能看出哪里不对劲。通常，即使是一个假车牌，在阳光下也会有不同的反光。在这个人的例子里，我能看出那是个遮挡的车牌。
A covered plate meaning it's in a little frame with some sort of plastic over the plate.
遮挡车牌是指它被装在一个小架子里，上面覆盖着某种塑料。
Now, plate covers are illegal in New York. This one's especially egregious because I don't know if you noticed-- and I'll just paint the word picture for your radio listeners-- it's a shaded one.
要知道，在纽约，车牌遮挡罩是违法的。这个特别过分，因为我不知道你有没有注意到——我会为电台听众描述一下——它是个有色遮挡罩。
Shaded with some special stuff so if you're in the car directly behind this car, it looks normal. But if you look down on the plate from above, the way traffic cameras do, it's black, unreadable. So those traffic cameras that catch you when you speed or run a red light, they do not deliver this person to justice with a ticket, or tolls, the cameras that read your plate and charge you $16 when you cross a bridge or tunnel into New York.
上面涂了某种特殊材料，所以如果你直接开车跟在这辆车后面，它看起来很正常。但如果你像交通摄像头那样从上方俯视车牌，它是黑色的，无法辨认。所以那些在你超速或闯红灯时抓拍你的交通摄像头，无法通过罚单将此人绳之以法；过路费也是如此，那些在你在进入纽约过桥或过隧道时读取车牌并扣除16美元费用的摄像头，对这辆车根本没用。
That doesn't work on this car. This person drives through for free every time. Taxpayers lose an estimated $194 million a year in lost fines and tolls because of unreadable plates. And most of the people Gersh catches doing this, evading the law this way, are cops.
这个人每次开车通过都是免费的。由于无法识别的车牌，纳税人每年估计损失1.94亿美元的罚款和过路费。而格什抓到的这些人中，大多是警察。
And once you start seeing it, you can't stop seeing it. The majority have been people in law enforcement-- court officers, firefighters, cops, DAs, federal officials.
一旦你开始注意到这一点，你就无法停止去注意它。大多数违规者都是执法人员——法庭官员、消防员、警察、地方检察官、联邦官员。
And you know that they're police officers because you see stuff on their dashboard, stuff like this.
而且你知道他们是警察，因为你会在仪表盘上看到东西，比如这些。
Yeah, placards, a lot of placards. Hotspots are near precincts, near firehouses, and definitely near courthouses.
是的，标牌，很多标牌。热点区域通常在警局、消防站附近，绝对少不了法院附近。
We're actually next to a courthouse in a detention center on a short block at Baxter and Bayard. And this car that Gersh has spotted, a gray Audi, is one of four that we see with obscured plates.
我们现在就在巴克斯特街和拜ard街拐角处，法院和拘留中心旁边的一个短街区。格什发现的这辆灰色奥迪，是我们看到的四辆车牌被遮挡的车之一。
You're looking on this front dashboard. What's it say there?
你正看着前仪表盘。上面写着什么？
Well, so this is actually the Manhattan Detention Complex authorized parking. This is a Department of Corrections employee placard. But if you notice, the plate was from Jersey.
嗯，这其实是曼哈顿拘留中心的授权停车证。这是惩教署员工的标牌。但如果你注意看，车牌是新泽西州的。
If the owner of the gray Audi is an employee of the New York City Department of Corrections, they're supposed to live in New York. It's forbidden for them to live in Jersey. And so they seem to be evading traffic cameras. Maybe they're living illegally out of state.
如果这辆灰色奥迪的车主是纽约市惩教署的员工，他们理应住在纽约。禁止他们住在新泽西。所以他们似乎是在躲避交通摄像头。也许他们是非法居住在外州。
And they've also got darkly tinted windows, which are illegal in New York, which means this is exactly the kind of scofflaw that Gersh has appointed himself to take action against. That's where Gersh is different from you and me.
而且他们的车窗贴了深色防爆膜，这在纽约也是违法的，这意味着这正是格什决意要采取行动的违规者类型。这就是格什和你我不一样的地方。
It's just-- what it is, is it just rankles me. It's just like-- it's hiding in plain sight.
其实……原因就是，这让我很恼火。就好像……这是一种明目张胆的掩盖。
He looks again at the placard under the car's windshield.
他再次看向汽车挡风玻璃下的标牌。
I mean, this guy's a real dick. You can't see. He's covered up when the placard expires. My guess is, this is an expired placard anyway. And he may not even work for the city of New York anymore, but he's decided he wants to park for free in an illegal parking zone.
我是说，这家伙真是个混蛋。你看不到。他把标牌的过期日期遮住了。我猜，这标牌反正也过期了。他可能甚至不再为纽约市工作了，但他决定要在违规停车区免费停车。
Now, what I will often do in these situations is, I'll remove the plate cover and stick it on the dash. I don't steal anything, but I do want the guy to know he's breaking the law, and a guy who works for corrections certainly should know what happens to people who break the law. And I have to look at it to see, can I even get it off? Yeah, I could get-- oh, no, he's got a special screw on this one.
在这种情况下，我通常会做的是，拆掉车牌罩并把它扔在仪表盘上。我没有偷任何东西，但我确实想让这家伙知道他在违法。一个为惩教署工作的人，理应知道违法的人会有什么下场。我得看看，我能不能把它拆下来？啊，不行，他这一个用了特殊螺丝。
The four screws on the plate need an Allen wrench.
车牌上的四颗螺丝需要内六角扳手。
I'm going to see if my Allen wrench will fit this one. If it will, I'll take it off, and we'll have some fun.
我看看我的内六角扳手能不能用。如果能，我就把它拆下来，我们要乐呵乐呵了。
OK, so you're pulling an Allen wrench out of your wallet.
好的，所以你从钱包里掏出了一个内六角扳手。
Well, I always have an Allen wrench in my wallet. You don't have an Allen wrench in your wallet? I don't have the right size Allen wrench. Let me check my bag. I travel with a set of tools.
嗯，我钱包里总是带着内六角扳手。你钱包里没有内六角扳手吗？我没带对尺寸。让我看看我的包，我随身带了一套工具。
He looks, but it turns out he doesn't have the right tool, so he leaves the license cover on the car. That's rare for Gersh, to not be able to fix the situation. Most times, what he finds is, drivers have painted over a letter or a number on the plate or bent the plate so it's unreadable. Or they've crammed leaves in the license plate holder. There are actually fake leaves with magnets you can buy online for this purpose.
他看了看，但发现没有合适的工具，所以只好把车牌罩留在了车上。这种情况对于格什来说很罕见，竟然无法解决问题。大多数时候，他发现司机们会用油漆涂掉车牌上的字母或数字，或者弯曲车牌让其无法辨认。或者他们会往车牌架里塞树叶。网上甚至有专门为此销售的带磁铁的假树叶。
Gersh removes the leaves, unbends the plates, repaints the letters and numbers with a paint marker, so in the end, the plate is perfectly legible again. He also shoots a video. Gersh always shoots a gleeful little video to post online.
格什会移走树叶，把车牌掰直，用油漆笔重新描绘字母和数字，最终让车牌恢复完美可读。他还会拍一段视频。格什总是会拍一段幸灾乐祸的小视频发到网上。
I usually start in the front.
我通常从车头开始。
He pulls out his phone, selfie style, and hits record.
他拿出手机，用自拍模式，按下录制键。
Well, hey, everybody. It's Gersh Kuntzman. It's Good Friday, and I want to say it's a great Friday. Look at this. I've got a corrections officer with a New Jersey car. It's a pretty fancy car with illegal tinted windows. And look at this. On the back of the car, he's got this weird, shadowy kind of plate cover, which doesn't--
嘿，大家好。我是格什·昆茨曼。今天是耶稣受难日，我想说这是个很棒的周五。看看这个。我抓到一个开新泽西牌照车的惩教官。这是一辆很高级的车，车窗有违法的深色膜。再看这个。车后，他有个奇怪的、遮挡性的车牌罩，它不……
He shows the viewers the plate cover and how it hides the plate from the cameras. He's done about 250 of these videos. Gersh's friends have tried to convince him to stop, scared some driver is going to freak out on him and really hurt him, so lately, he's agreed not to do this alone, though, sometimes, he says, he can't stop himself.
他向观众展示了车牌罩是如何让摄像头无法读取车牌的。他已经拍了大约250段这样的视频。格什的朋友们试图劝他停止，担心某些司机会对他发火并真的伤害他，所以最近他同意不再单独行动，尽管有时他说他自己也忍不住。
The way Gersh got into this, he's a journalist who writes about these sorts of issues. He runs a traffic and transit news site called Streetsblog. He says that when speed enforcement cameras went on 24/7 in New York-- this was back in August 2022-- and lots of people back then started defacing their plates to avoid the cameras.
格什从事这一行，是因为他是一名撰写此类议题的记者。他经营着一个名为Streetsblog的交通和运输新闻网站。他说，当纽约的超速监控摄像头在2022年8月实现24/7全天候监控时，很多人在那时开始损毁车牌以规避监控。
He didn't get involved in the issue himself until a friend of his, a guy named Adam White, a personal injuries lawyer and a safe streets activist, decided to take action. Adam saw an SUV whose plate was obscured by a piece of plastic.
他自己并没有参与此事，直到他的一个朋友，名叫亚当·怀特（Adam White），一位人身伤害律师和安全街道倡导者，决定采取行动。亚当看到一辆SUV的车牌被一片塑料遮挡了。
So he moved the piece of plastic. Unfortunately, for him, he didn't look in the car. The guy was sitting right there. The guy was also a cop.
于是他移开了那片塑料。不幸的是，他没有查看车里有没有人。那家伙就坐在那儿。而且那家伙还是个警察。
To be precise, the guy was not a real NYPD cop. He was in a local neighborhood patrol.
准确来说，那家伙不是真正的纽约警局警察。他是社区巡逻队的。
So he called the cops, and the cops arrested Adam and charged him with criminal mischief. Now, that's the most hysterical part of it because criminal mischief is generally like a graffiti charge. Like, if you damage someone's property, you get charged with criminal mischief.
所以他叫了警察，警察逮捕了亚当并以刑事毁坏罪起诉他。这是最荒唐的部分，因为刑事毁坏罪通常是指涂鸦那种性质。比如，如果你损坏了别人的财产，就会被控刑事毁坏。
In this case, it's a weird charge because he didn't actually damage anything-- he actually undamaged or repaired the damage the other guy did by covering his plate. So, anyway, he was arrested, but it was dismissed. But at the same time, once he got arrested by a cop for undefacing a cop's plate, it kind of threw the whole irony ball in the air, and I felt like I should just juggle it.
在这个案例中，指控很怪，因为他并没有损坏任何东西——他实际上是修复了对方通过遮挡车牌而造成的“损坏”。总之，他被捕了，但后来指控被驳回了。但同时，当他因为把警察的车牌“未毁坏”而被警察逮捕时，这就把整个荒谬的球抛到了空中，我觉得我应该接住它。
["CRIMINAL MISCHIEF (FOR ADAM WHITE)" BY JIMMY AND THE JAYWALKERS]
["刑事毁坏（致亚当·怀特）" —— 吉米和乱穿马路者乐队]
The first spin of the irony ball for Gersh was a kind of Dylanesque protest song that he wrote for his friend Adam.
格什第一次转动这个荒谬之球，是他为朋友亚当写的一首类似迪伦风格的抗议歌曲。
(SUBJECT) JIMMY AND THE JAYWALKERS: (SINGING) The cops call it criminal mischief
（主题）吉米和乱穿马路者乐队：（演唱）警察称之为刑事毁坏
Then, maybe two days after Adam was arrested, Gersh started unvandalizing plates himself.
然后，就在亚当被捕后大概两天，格什开始亲自“反破坏”车牌。
Something clicked in me, saying, wait a minute, I should try to get arrested as a newspaper reporter, as a journalist, which would be awesome getting arrested, or even better yet, like getting punched out by somebody on camera. Like, this is the height of my career. I'm not going to win a Pulitzer, but getting punched out by a cop would be awesome.
我心里有什么东西被触动了，我在想，等等，我应该尝试作为一名报社记者，一名新闻工作者被捕，那会很酷。或者更好的是，在摄像机前被某人揍一顿。这简直是我职业生涯的巅峰。我虽然拿不到普利策奖，但能被警察揍一顿绝对太棒了。
That hasn't happened, not even close, though Gersh has seen some other responses by law enforcement to his videos. When he shoots one, he likes to send it to the agency that employs that particular car owner. So videos about scofflaw cops go to the NYPD, firefighters to the fire department, and so on.
这还没发生，甚至离那还远着呢，不过格什已经看到执法部门对他的视频做出了一些其他反应。当他拍完一段视频后，他喜欢把它发给该车主的雇佣机构。所以关于违规警察的视频会发给纽约警局，消防员的发给消防部门，以此类推。
And that's gotten occasional results. A former cop who was working with the DA's office resigned, and a guy that Gersh caught five times hiding his license plate with leaves resigned from the Department of Citywide Administrative Services.
这偶尔会产生一些结果。一名曾在地方检察官办公室工作的退休警察辞职了，而格什抓到五次用树叶遮挡车牌的家伙也从市行政服务局辞职了。
Now, in fairness, I will say, I think the NYPD did something because about six months ago, I started noticing far fewer police officers were defacing or covering their plate. There have been less police officers involved in these kind of shenanigans. I still notice court officers, federal officials, and firefighters. So and then I asked the NYPD about that, and they won't even take credit for when they do something right. They're a very opaque agency, which is very frustrating.
当然，公平地说，我觉得纽约警局确实采取了一些行动，因为大约六个月前，我开始注意到警察损毁或遮挡车牌的情况少多了。参与这些把戏的警察变少了。我仍然能注意到法庭官员、联邦官员和消防员（在这样做）。所以，当我问纽约警局有关情况时，他们甚至不愿在做了正确的事情时居功。他们是一个非常封闭的机构，这很令人沮丧。
There are a handful of other people in New York who do this kind of license plate street justice, but Gersh is the most visible by far because of his videos. He's gotten the word out. At this point, Gersh's exploits have been written up in The New Yorker and The New York Times. He's been on TV.
纽约还有少数人做这种车牌街道正义的事，但格什因为他的视频是其中最引人注目的。他已经让消息传开了。目前，格什的事迹已经被《纽约客》和《纽约时报》报道过。他上过电视。
So, it's weird, in some ways. Like I've been a reporter for 30 something years in this city, and this is ultimately the most successful thing I've done in terms of bringing light to something that is actually a real problem. Traffic enforcement agents are now writing more tickets for it.
所以，这在某些方面很奇怪。我在这个城市做记者三十多年了，而这最终是我在让大家关注一个真正的问题方面所做的最成功的事情。交通执法人员现在正在为此开出更多的罚单。
That said, the wrong that Gersh is trying to correct is so small in the grand scheme of things. Why is he the person who ended up leading the crusade for unobstructed license plates? He told me he's not this way with other petty crimes. He sees somebody jumping a turnstile, he doesn't care. But this got under his skin. A license plate seems like such basic accountability to him. But also--
话虽如此，格什试图纠正的错误在宏观层面上是如此微小。为什么最后是他成了一场争取车牌不受遮挡的运动的领头人？他告诉我，他在处理其他轻微罪行时并不是这样。他看到有人跳闸机逃票，他根本不在乎。但这件事触动了他的神经。对他来说，车牌似乎代表着最基本的问责制。但还有……
A bit of a showman. I'm a bit of a showman, I'll admit that. Yes, I am a ham. I am a performer. But why can't a journalist have a little fun?
有点像个表演者。我确实有点表演欲，我承认这一点。是的，我就是爱表现。我是一个表演者。但为什么记者就不能有一点乐趣呢？
That's actually one of my favorite things about Gersh's videos. He looks like he's having so much fun.
这其实是我最喜欢格什视频的一点。他看起来玩得很开心。
You know, New York life, it doesn't have a lot of joy in it. It really doesn't. Like, it's really kind of drudgery most of the time. It's a great city, whatever, but it's drudgery. And those 20 seconds a day when I can do one of those videos, I get joyful. You see me on camera, and I'm smiling. And I don't know what it is. It's just like my inner soul is just singing.
你知道，纽约的生活，并没有多少乐趣。真的没有。大部分时间其实就是苦差事。这城市很伟大什么的，但就是苦差事。而每天那20秒，当我可以录制那些视频时，我感到快乐。你在镜头里看到我，我在笑。我不知道为什么。就好像我的内心在歌唱。
Well, today on our program, minor crimes and the people who appoint themselves to stop those minor crimes. I once read this great crime writer who said that what's interesting about a murder case is that a murder reveals so much about all the people near the crime. We see who they really are.
好了，今天在我们的节目里，我们聊聊轻微罪行以及那些自愿去阻止这些轻微罪行的人。我曾读到过一位伟大的犯罪作家说，谋杀案之所以有趣，是因为谋杀揭示了犯罪现场附近所有人太多的信息。我们看到了他们真实的面目。
Today on our show, we demonstrate that this is not just true for a cold-blooded crime in the first degree, it's true for the tiniest human infractions, like kids stealing candy, or a man who twice violates the lowest level municipal offense that you can think of. We see so much about who they are. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目里，我们证明这不仅适用于一级冷血谋杀罪，也适用于最微小的人性违规，比如孩子偷糖果，或者一个两次违反你能想到的最低级别市政法规的男人。我们看到了关于他们是谁的太多真相。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "Harriot versus Harriot." OK, so let's kick things off today with an entire system of justice set up to adjudicate the most minor sorts of crimes and misdemeanors. When Michael Harriot was a kid, growing up in South Carolina in the '80s, his mom set this up, a kind of courtroom in the house to try to teach her kids all kinds of life lessons. They called it Harriot Court, and when one of the kids did something wrong, the case would be heard, a judgment would be handed down.
第一幕，“哈里奥特诉哈里奥特”。好了，今天让我们从一整套旨在审判最轻微罪行和过失的司法系统开始。迈克尔·哈里奥特小时候，在80年代的南卡罗来纳州长大，他妈妈设立了这个系统，一个家里的法庭，用来教孩子们各种人生课程。他们称之为“哈里奥特法庭”，当其中一个孩子犯错时，案件就会被审理，判决就会下达。
This ran for many, many years with all kinds of cases. And Michael says that he and his siblings all credit Harriot Court with making them the people they are today, though, when I went to talk to them about it recently, he started to rethink that.
这个法庭运行了很多年，审理了各种案件。迈克尔说他和他的兄弟姐妹都认为“哈里奥特法庭”塑造了今天的他们，不过，当我最近和他们谈论此事时，他开始重新思考这一点。
Harriot Court existed for a reason. We were bad. There were four of us, me and three sisters. Sean was the oldest.
哈里奥特法庭的存在是有原因的。我们很淘气。我们有四个孩子，我和三个姐妹。肖恩是老大。
So growing up, I would describe myself as-- I was a snitch. I'm just going to say it, the tattle tale. I would say, back then, I was the bossiest 'cause I was the one that was always in charge, and I could spank everybody.
所以长大的过程中，我会这样描述自己——我是一个告密者。我就直说吧，爱打小报告的人。那时我是最专横的，因为我总是在管事，我可以打所有人的屁股。
I was the middle child, the nerd and the know-it-all, the sneakiest of the bunch. Then there were the two youngest girls, Comelita and Robin.
我是中间的孩子，书呆子和自以为是的人，是一群里最鬼鬼祟祟的。然后是两个最小的女孩，科梅丽塔和罗宾。
Comelita and Robin were like-- they was just what you call the wild childs. It was just whatever with them. If it could be done, they did it. They're gonna try it.
科梅丽塔和罗宾就像……她们就是所谓的“野孩子”。对她们来说什么都无所谓。只要能做到的，她们就做。她们什么都想尝试。
They were born months apart, and Robin passed away some years ago. But no one ever really thought of Comelita and Robin as individuals. They were one interconnected unit, like Tom and Jerry, Bonnie and Clyde, or Earth, Wind, and Fire. Here's Comelita.
她们出生仅差几个月，罗宾几年前去世了。但没人真正把科梅丽塔和罗宾视为独立的个体。她们是一个互联的整体，就像汤姆和杰瑞，邦妮和克莱德，或者“地球、风与火”乐团。这是科梅丽塔。
They used to call us the devil and Daniel Webster because whatever I came up with, she would follow me, or whatever she came up with, I'm going with you, girl. We're doing it together. We went to school together. We wore the same clothes. We graduated the same year. So she had my back.
他们过去常叫我们“魔鬼与丹尼尔·韦伯斯特”，因为无论我提出什么点子，她都会跟着我；或者无论她想出什么点子，我都会说，我也去，姐妹。我们一起干。我们一起上学。我们穿一样的衣服。我们同年毕业。所以她总是支持我。
And then there was my mom. My mom was not one of those "because I said so" kind of moms. She wanted us to know that we would be heard, and that logic and reason should govern the world and our household, so she created Harriot Court as a solution to our shenanigans. My mom was two people at once. She was part of a fundamentalist holiness religion, and she was this pro-Black, Black Panther-ish activist, who was almost obsessively adamant about our education.
然后还有我妈。我妈不是那种说“因为我说了算”类型的妈妈。她希望我们知道我们会得到倾听，逻辑和理性应该主宰世界和我们的家庭，所以她创立了哈里奥特法庭来解决我们的淘气行为。我妈同时是两个人。她是某种原教旨主义圣洁宗教的信徒，同时又是一个亲黑人、有点黑豹党风格的活动家，对我们的教育几乎到了痴迷的程度。
She didn't really trust white people with her kids, so for a while, we were homeschooled. As a result, so much of what we learned came from TV, including Harriot Court proceedings. We hired each other as attorneys and used phrases like, "ladies and gentlemen of the jury," and "I beseech thee." We beseeched each other a lot.
她不太相信白人能教好她的孩子，所以有一段时间，我们在家上学。结果，我们学到的很多东西都来自电视，包括哈里奥特法庭的程序。我们雇佣彼此作为律师，使用像“陪审团的先生女士们”和“我恳请你”这样的措辞。我们经常互相恳求。
One of the earliest cases was Comelita and Robin versus All This Candy. As a rule, we were not allowed to have candy growing up, except for once a week, usually on Fridays. That was tough for my sister Comelita, who was obsessed with candy.
最早的案件之一是“科梅丽塔和罗宾诉所有这些糖果”。按规定，我们长大的过程中是不允许吃糖果的，除非一周一次，通常在周五。这对我妹妹科梅丽塔来说很难，她对糖果着迷。
We used to get the Hubba Bubba because it used to be strawberry or banana, and it was five pieces. So we got a pack of Lifesavers and either Chicklets or Hubba Bubba Bubble Gum.
我们过去常买Hubba Bubba泡泡糖，因为它有草莓或香蕉味的，而且一包有五块。所以我们买了Lifesavers糖果和Chicklets口香糖或Hubba Bubba。
I don't love candy like y'all love candy.
我不像你们那么爱吃糖果。
Me and Robin loved candy. We love candy.
我和罗宾爱吃糖果。我们爱吃糖果。
So take us through the candy case.
那么带我们重温一下糖果案。
Well, me and Robin stole the candy from the corner store.
嗯，我和罗宾从街角商店偷了糖果。
I-- So me and Sean thought y'all found some money and bought that candy.
我……我和肖恩以为你们是捡到了钱买了糖果。
No, we stole the candy. We stole the candy, but we kept stealing it and stealing it. It was so much candy. It was like Halloween candy. I'm talking about bags you would get and take from your kids at Halloween. That's how much candy it was. But there was no place for anybody to hide it, so we hid it under the mattress. And me and Robin kept saying, just put it in the mattress. They ain't gonna find it. Just put it in the mattress.
不，我们偷了糖果。我们偷了糖果，而且一直偷一直偷。糖果太多了。就像万圣节糖果一样。我说的是那种你从万圣节孩子手里没收来的那种袋装糖果。就是那么多。但是没人有地方藏，所以我们把它们藏在床垫下面。我和罗宾一直说，就塞进床垫里。他们找不到的。就塞进床垫里。
So we put it in the mattress. And then one day, Mama said, well, we're gonna clean from under the mattress. And she flipped the mattress, and the candy was under the mattress. So we had to go to court and tell where we got the candy from, why we had so much-- because it was a lot, like two Piggly Wiggly bags full.
于是我们把它们塞进了床垫。然后有一天，妈妈说，我们要清理床垫下面的灰尘。她翻开了床垫，糖果就在下面。所以我们不得不去法庭交代这些糖果是从哪来的，为什么我们有这么多——因为那真的很多，就像两整袋Piggly Wiggly超市的袋子。
Robin and Comelita put me on retainer as their defense attorney in exchange for them doing one of my household chores. We gathered in the den, which we call the middle room, where Chief Justice Dorothy Harriot presided. She would sit in the canary yellow La-Z-Boy, and we'd plead our case from the couch/witness box.
罗宾和科梅丽塔雇我做她们的辩护律师，代价是她们帮我做一件家务。我们聚集在书房，也就是我们说的“中间房间”，多萝西·哈里奥特大法官在那里主持。她会坐在那张金丝雀黄色的躺椅上，我们就在沙发/证人席上辩论我们的案件。
We swore each other in on a copy of our favorite book. Encyclopedia Brown was mine. And I came up with a defense that I still argue should have worked because, remember, we weren't allowed to eat candy.
我们用我们最爱的一本书宣誓。我的那本是《百科全书布朗》。我想出了一个辩护策略，我至今仍认为那本该起效的，因为记住，我们是不允许吃糖果的。
My defense was that she didn't catch y'all eating candy. She can't prove that y'all ate the candy. Y'all just had the candy. How she know y'all wasn't trying to sell candy?
我的辩护是，她没有抓到你们正在吃糖果。她不能证明你们吃了糖果。你们只是有糖果而已。她怎么知道你们不是在试图转卖糖果？
No, no, no, we was eating that candy.
不，不，不，我们就是在吃糖果。
I know y'all was eating it. But that was my defense.
我知道你们在吃。但这曾是我的辩护词。
I don't remember exactly, but mom would have cross-examined Comelita and Robin. She probably asked them if they understood why we couldn't have candy. It was because I had ADHD, which my mom believed got worse with sugar. After we'd made our arguments, our mom dismissed Harriot Court by saying, OK, make good choices. Then she'd deliberate before issuing a written opinion-- yes, a written opinion-- which would be taped to our doors.
我不记得具体细节了，但妈妈肯定盘问过科梅丽塔和罗宾。她可能问过她们是否明白为什么我们不能吃糖果。那是因为我有ADHD（多动症），我妈认为这在摄入糖分后会恶化。在我们陈述完观点后，妈妈会说“好了，做出好的选择”来结束哈里奥特法庭的审判。然后她会进行审议，最后发布一份书面意见——没错，书面意见——然后贴在我们门上。
Describe how you used to feel like in your body when you was waiting for her to decide.
描述一下当你等待她做决定时，你的身体是什么感觉。
Oh, my God. Like the world's gonna come to an end, like it was anything. It might be the next day. It might be the same night. You didn't know what was going to happen. And you would just take the paper, and it'd be folded up, and you'd have to read your decision. But you know what? She never said, well, let me consult with somebody else. It was all-- [LAUGHS]
哦，天哪。就像世界末日要来了一样，那种感觉简直了。可能是第二天，也可能是当晚。你不知道会发生什么。你会接过纸条，它是折叠好的，你必须阅读判决结果。但你知道吗？她从不说“嗯，让我咨询一下别人”。一切都是……（笑）
You're right. She didn't never consult with anybody.
你说得对。她从不咨询任何人。
She didn't consult with anybody. No appeals. It was what she said was it.
她不咨询任何人。没有上诉。她说的话就是最终裁定。
The sentences were usually something like a week of extra chores or two weeks in solitary bedroom confinement, which happened so frequently, it eventually became known as being "on punishment." And because we didn't go to school and only had each other to play with, those in-room incarceration periods seemed unbearably long.
惩罚通常是一周额外的家务，或者两周的卧室禁闭，这种情况发生得太频繁了，以至于后来被称为“受惩罚”。由于我们不上学，只能一起玩，那些房间里的监禁期显得漫长得令人难以忍受。
And that was the point. The punishment gave you time to learn from your mistakes. In the candy case, Mom came down hard on Comelita and Robin. They were on punishment for a long time, and they both never stole candy again.
这正是重点。惩罚给了你从错误中吸取教训的时间。在糖果案中，妈妈对科梅丽塔和罗宾很严厉。她们被关了很久的禁闭，从此以后两人再也没有偷过糖果。
For years, I've remembered the candy case as an example of the court working the best, but when I talked to Comelita about it recently, she made me look at things a little differently.
多年来，我一直把糖果案视为法庭运行得最好的例子，但当我最近和科梅丽塔谈起这件事时，她让我从不同的角度看待它。
We was on punishment a long time. But it didn't matter with me and Robin because we used to always do what we wasn't supposed to do anyway. Mama was at work, so me and Robin would do whatever we wanted to do up until we knew it was time for her to come home. So it really didn't matter.
我们被关了很久。但我和罗宾并不在乎，因为我们本来就一直做着我们不该做的事。妈妈上班去了，所以我和罗宾在知道她快要下班回家之前，想做什么就做什么。所以其实根本没影响。
Comelita didn't stop misbehaving. I can just see her, sitting in her room, thinking over the lessons she learned from the candy case-- find a better hiding spot. So maybe it wasn't the perfect criminal justice system.
科梅丽塔并没有停止捣乱。我能想象她坐在房间里思考从糖果案中学到的教训——找个更好的藏匿点。所以也许这并不是一个完美的刑事司法系统。
And the more I think about it, there seemed to be a lot of cases like this, ones that showed, in retrospect, that our beloved Harriot Court was kind of flawed, like the case of Sean versus the Big Lie, which started when my mom eventually allowed us to attend public school.
我越想越觉得，像这样的案件有很多，回想起来，它们表明我们深爱的哈里奥特法庭其实是有缺陷的，比如“肖恩诉大谎言案”，这件事始于我妈最终允许我们上公立学校。
I think I might have been in fifth or sixth grade. And I went to the school, and I told them I was dying.
我想我可能在五六年级。我去学校告诉他们我快死了。
I forgot about that! [LAUGHS] Go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead.
我忘了那个了！（笑）继续。继续。继续。
I told them I was dying. I had this undetermined disease that nobody knew about. And literally, the whole grade was like, oh, my goodness, she's dying. They don't know how much time she's gonna have. So they would come in, sign my desk, and do all that stuff. And so, even the teachers, they was feeling bad. The principal, they were feeling bad.
我告诉他们我快死了。我患有一种没人知道的未确诊疾病。字面意义上，整个年级的人都觉得，哦，天哪，她快死了。他们不知道她还能活多久。所以他们会走进来，在我的课桌上签名，做所有那一套。甚至连老师们都觉得很难过。校长也觉得很难过。
Sean's classmates raised money for her unnamed terminal illness and even signed a huge poster that was supposed to go in her casket. She kept this lie going for months, until my mom found out about it.
肖恩的同学们为她未知的绝症筹了款，甚至签了一张巨大的海报，原本是打算放在她棺材里的。她把这个谎言维持了几个月，直到我妈发现了。
I think it was like parent-teacher conference or something. And so, my mom went, and the teacher was just expressing how she was feeling bad and asking about everything that was going on. She even showed her how I had the people signing on my desk and everything.
我想那是在家长教师联谊会之类的活动上。所以，我妈去了，老师正在表达她感到多么难过，并询问有关一切正在发生的事情。她甚至向我妈展示了大家是如何在我的课桌上签名的。
And oh, boy, when she got home, she asked me, was like, well, when are you supposed to be dying? And I just can't-- you know how you lose your breath? You're like, hmm? Huh? And she was like, so you're gonna be sick for real. [LAUGHS] You're really gonna be sick, for real.
哦，天哪，当她到家后，她问我，她说，嗯，你打算什么时候死？我只是……你知道那种喘不过气来的感觉吗？你在想，嗯？哈？然后她说，所以你真的要生病了。（笑）你真的要生病了，认真的那种。
Lying was a big deal in our house. We weren't even allowed to say the word "lie." Sean called for a Harriot court trial, but really, it was just a delay tactic. She knew she didn't have a case. She was just trying to buy time, hoping my mom would cool off. It didn't work. The case went to trial, and my mom put her on punishment for weeks.
撒谎在我们家里是大事。我们甚至不允许说“谎言”这个词。肖恩要求进行一次哈里奥特法庭审判，但实际上，那只是拖延战术。她知道自己站不住脚。她只是想争取时间，希望我妈能消消气。没用。案件进入审判，我妈惩罚她关禁闭关了几个星期。
Sean never told another lie like that again, unless you count that time she lied about going to spring break in '94. But the thing I realized, when I talked to her, was she wasn't just acting out for no reason. This new school was a totally different environment. At home, she was the tough older sister. But at school, she was crying every day.
肖恩再也没有撒过那样的谎，除非算上她在94年春假撒谎的那次。但我意识到，当我跟她谈话时，她并不是无缘无故地闹事。这所新学校是一个完全不同的环境。在家时，她是那个强硬的大姐姐。但在学校，她每天都在哭。
It was a culture shock for us. Totally different school, totally different neighborhood. I mean, predominantly white people, like literally. I ain't have a lot of friends. I only had like maybe three or four friends that, like I really did. And I think that was probably the reason why I actually started doing it. And I was like, hmm, it's getting me some attention, so I'm just going to keep going.
这对我们来说是文化冲击。完全不同的学校，完全不同的社区。我是说，主要是白人，字面意义上。我没有多少朋友。我只有三四个真心朋友。我想那可能就是我开始撒谎的原因。我当时想，嗯，这能让我得到一些关注，所以我打算继续下去。
Looking back, I can't say that Harriot Court worked in this instance. Sean was lonely, and she needed attention, so she acted out by telling a lie. My mom punished her for the lie, but it didn't help her make friends. Like the real world criminal justice system, Harriot Court didn't address the root cause of the problem it was trying to fix.
回想起来，我不能说哈里奥特法庭在这一例中起到了作用。肖恩很孤独，她需要关注，所以她通过撒谎来博取注意。我妈因为谎言惩罚了她，但这并没有帮她交到朋友。就像现实世界的刑事司法系统一样，哈里奥特法庭并没有解决它试图修复问题的根本原因。
Over the years, as we learned about the real world, Harriot Court became more complex. The "ass case" addressed the no profanity rule. We used the court to establish precedent, like "I was doing it first," which stated that you weren't breaking the no hitting rule, as long as you were moving your arm and yelling, "I was doing this first!" After all, it wasn't your fault if someone got clocked upside the head. You were doing it first.
多年来，随着我们对现实世界的了解，哈里奥特法庭变得更加复杂。“屁股案”处理了禁止脏话的规则。我们利用法庭建立先例，比如“我先开始的”，它规定只要你挥动手臂并大喊“我先开始的！”，你就没有违反禁止击打的规则。毕竟，如果有人被打到了脑袋，那不是你的错。是你先开始的。
We even used it to overturn previous verdicts, like the one that enforced our religion's ban against women wearing pants. In Harriot Court, we successfully convinced my mom to overturn the no pants rule, so Sean could play softball. And as with any justice system, over time, my sisters and I found loopholes that we could use to subvert our mom's strict rules.
我们甚至利用它推翻了之前的裁决，比如那条强制执行我们宗教禁忌、禁止女性穿裤子的规定。在哈里奥特法庭，我们成功说服我妈废除了禁穿裤子的规定，这样肖恩就可以打垒球。随着时间推移，和任何司法系统一样，我和姐妹们找到了可以利用的漏洞，来颠覆我妈严格的规则。
We became a team of semi-crooked lawyers, the esteemed firm of Harriot, Harriot, Harriot, and another Harriot. Sometimes we faced each other in court, which brings us to the last case, which is about me, Michael versus Syrup. As the oldest, one of Sean's many responsibilities was operating the washing machine. She was the only sibling allowed to do it.
我们成了一支半吊子律师团队，著名的“哈里奥特、哈里奥特、哈里奥特和另一个哈里奥特”事务所。有时我们在法庭上对阵，这就引出了最后一个案件，关于我的——“迈克尔诉糖浆案”。作为老大，肖恩的众多职责之一是操作洗衣机。她是唯一被允许操作洗衣机的姐妹。
So I was the person that had to wash the clothes. I would wash the clothes, and the other girls would either put them in the dryer or hang them out, whatever needed to be done to them. And he didn't do anything, except empty the trash when he was told.
所以我是那个必须洗衣服的人。我洗衣服，其他姐妹要么把衣服放进烘干机，要么挂出去，总之需要做什么就做什么。而他什么都不做，除了被叫到时去倒垃圾。
I had to do the yards. I had to lift all the stuff in the house. Like--
我得清理院子。我得在家里搬所有重物。就像……
How often was that, though? How often was that? That was not that often. That was not that often.
那有多频繁？有多频繁？那不常发生。那不常发生。
Sean always felt like I wasn't doing enough. And as the person whose sisters nicknamed him "the absent-minded professor," I was the only sibling who regularly forgot to give her my clothes. One day, she finally reached the tipping point and exacted her revenge.
肖恩总觉得我做得不够多。作为被姐妹们戏称为“健忘教授”的人，我是唯一一个经常忘记把衣服交给她的孩子。有一天，她终于达到了忍耐极限，展开了报复。
I literally was like, I'm not washing your clothes anymore. I'm like, I'm not doing it anymore. And I washed everybody's clothes except his that week.
我简直就是说，我不给你洗衣服了。我说，我再也不干了。那周我洗了所有人的衣服，除了他的。
But the next day was Picture Day. I think you left that important detail out. It was picture day.
但第二天是拍照片日。我想你漏掉了那个重要细节。那是拍照片日。
I was furious. Sean's petty vengeance meant I wouldn't have my favorite shirt on one of the most important events on the elementary school calendar-- picture day.
我气疯了。肖恩的小气报复意味着我无法在小学日历上最重要的事情之一——拍照片日——穿上我最喜欢的衬衫。
And if you wonder why I couldn't just convince her to do another load, that wasn't even an option. Two loads? In one week? In the Harriot house? Does my mom look like Daddy Warbucks to you? So, because of my mom's one load per week rule, I had no choice but to find a loophole that could get me what I wanted.
如果你想问为什么我不能说服她多洗一桶，那根本不在选项里。两桶？一周之内？在哈里奥特家？你觉得我妈看起来像百万富翁吗？所以，因为我妈那个“一周一桶”的规则，我别无选择，只能找到一个能得到我想要的漏洞。
So we would like get our clothes out at night. For some reason, that particular night, I didn't get my clothes out. And then when I went to really go get my clothes out, and it was like syrup all over my clothes in the drawer.
我们通常晚上把衣服拿出来。不知为何，那天晚上我没把衣服拿出来。当我真正去拿衣服时，抽屉里到处都是糖浆。
I had snuck into her room with a bottle of Cane Patch syrup and poured it all over her clothes. Of course, she was upset, but this was all part of my plan. Now that we were both without clothes for Picture Day, there was only one place we could settle our differences-- Harriot Court. I argued that the solution was for my mom to grant a one-time special exemption from the one load rule. I won.
我偷偷溜进她的房间，拿着一瓶Cane Patch糖浆，倒在了她所有的衣服上。当然，她很生气，但这都是我计划的一部分。现在我们两人都没有衣服穿去拍照了，只有一个地方能解决我们的分歧——哈里奥特法庭。我辩称解决方案是我妈允许一次性特例，免除“一周一桶”的规则。我赢了。
She was like, well, since you got to wash those anyway, you might as well wash his clothes since you got to wash them anyway. So I was like, I literally had to wash all my clothes over, plus his clothes. And he was the one who put the syrup on my clothes.
她说，好吧，既然你反正得洗那些，既然你无论如何都得洗，不如连他的衣服也一起洗了。所以我当时就想……我得重新洗一遍我所有的衣服，再加上他的。而他才是把糖浆倒在我衣服上的人。
Sean had to pay for a crime that I committed, while I escaped without punishment. In the moment when I won, I felt great. I ran around the middle room, gloating about my superior legal skills.
肖恩不得不为我犯下的罪行买单，而我却逃脱了惩罚。在赢得胜利的那一刻，我感觉棒极了。我在中间房间跑来跑去，炫耀我卓越的法律技巧。
But when I went to my bedroom afterwards, which was next to the laundry room, I could hear her sobbing to herself, as she tossed those clothes in the washing machine. I felt terrible. I hurt my sister just to get my way, and I'd done it in the worst way possible-- by weaponizing an institution that was created to give us justice. I was just another lawyer gaming the system. Perry Mason would never.
但之后当我回到卧室——就在洗衣房隔壁——我能听到她一边把那些衣服扔进洗衣机，一边独自啜泣。我感觉糟透了。我为了达到目的伤害了我的姐妹，而且我是用最糟糕的方式做到的——武器化了一个旨在给我们正义的机构。我只是另一个利用规则玩弄系统的律师。佩里·梅森（注：虚构著名律师）绝不会这么做。
30 years later, my sisters and I have never really talked to our mom about Harriot Court. She was the person who wrote the rules and made the decisions, but I've never asked her if her system worked as she intended or why she started it in the first place. Turns out, she didn't just create it to keep us in check.
30年后，我和姐妹们从来没真正跟妈妈聊过哈里奥特法庭。她是那个制定规则并做决定的人，但我从未问过她这个系统是否如她预想的那样运作，或者她最初为什么要建立它。事实证明，她建立它不仅仅是为了约束我们。
My secret ambition was to go to law school. Even now, today, my favorite TV show is Judge Judy. [LAUGHS] So I watch Judge Judy. I watch Trish.
我的秘密野心是上法学院。即便现在，今天，我最喜欢的电视节目也是《朱迪法官》。（笑）我看着《朱迪法官》。我看着《特里什》。
Ladies and gentlemen of the jury, my mom, the honorable Dorothy Harriot.
陪审团的先生女士们，我的妈妈，荣誉的多萝西·哈里奥特。
Well, we used to watch People's Court. Y'all had to watch People's Court because I watched it all the time. And I can't remember that judge's name.
嗯，我们过去常看《人民法庭》。你们必须看《人民法庭》，因为我一直都在看。我不记得那位法官的名字了。
Judge Wapner. Joe Wapner. Judge Wapner.
瓦普纳法官。乔·瓦普纳。瓦普纳法官。
Yeah, but those are my favorite shows, even today. I should have gone to law school. I didn't because I didn't think I could pass the LSAT. I probably could have, but I was afraid to take it.
是的，那是我最喜欢的节目，即便是在今天。我本该上法学院的。我没去是因为我觉得我考不过LSAT（法学院入学考试）。我可能考得过，但我害怕去考。
My mother says, honestly, for her, Harriot Court was partly for her own enjoyment. She loved arguing with me, although she told me, I wasn't the young legal eagle I remembered, which stung. In my head, I thought I was one of the most persuasive attorneys.
我妈说，老实说，对她而言，“哈里奥特法庭”一部分是为了她自己的乐趣。她喜欢跟我争论，尽管她告诉我，我并不是我记忆中那个年轻的法律天才，这很伤人。在我脑海里，我以为我是最善辩的律师之一。
Had you already made up your mind when you rendered your decisions?
当你做出决定时，你是否已经下定决心了？
Most of the time, yes, because I had already thought about it, whatever we were judging and whatever we were going to court for.
大多数时候是的，因为无论我们审判什么，无论我们为什么要上法庭，我早就想好了。
So our arguments didn't sway you at all?
所以我们的辩论根本没动摇你？
No, because I had already made up my mind that y'all ain't had no couth and no do right in y'all. None of y'all.
没有，因为我早就认定你们根本没有教养，也没有正义感。你们中任何一个都没有。
So--
所以……
So it was down to Comelita.
所以这就取决于科梅丽塔了。
So why--
所以为什么……
Why even--
为什么还要……
Why have the court? Yeah.
为什么要设这个法庭？是的。
Because I wanted to be fair. I wanted y'all to think I was being fair.
因为我想做到公平。我希望你们觉得我是在公平行事。
Were you being fair?
你做到公平了吗？
I think I was pretty fair.
我觉得我相当公平。
Did you think it made us better behaved, worse behaved, or no change?
你觉得它让我们表现得更好，还是更差，或者没有变化？
I don't think it really made a difference with y'all. Y'all were just bad. Nobody could come up with the things that y'all did. Y'all were just some bad children. To be honest, today, y'all still them children. Y'all the James Avenue bad children.
我不觉得这对你们有什么真正的改变。你们就是淘气。没有人能想出你们干出来的那些事。你们就是一群坏孩子。老实说，今天，你们仍然是那些孩子。你们就是詹姆斯大道的坏孩子们。
Come to think of it, my sisters and I never really changed that much. Comelita is still the most rebellious. Sean is still the snitch who will tell Mom, you know that's whiskey in Mikey's cup.
回想起来，我和姐妹们确实从来没怎么变过。科梅丽塔仍然是最叛逆的。肖恩仍然是那个会告诉妈妈“你知道迈基杯子里是威士忌”的告密者。
And me, I'm still the same "let me explain why I'm correct" know-it-all, who my mom once called a right supremacist. But the court did one thing. It turned me and my sisters into a team. It was us versus the judge, us trying to outthink Mom.
至于我，我仍然是那个自以为是的“让我解释为什么我是对的”的家伙，我妈曾经称我是“权利至上主义者”。但这个法庭确实做成了一件事。它把我和我的姐妹们变成了一个团队。那是我们对阵法官，我们试图在智力上胜过妈妈。
I created that atmosphere on purpose. I wanted you guys to know how to stand your own ground and to be honest about who you were and what you were doing. And I think I made that point. Court made that point. It taught you guys loyalty to each other and the fact that y'all didn't snitch on each other, and y'all still don't snitch on each other.
我故意制造了那种氛围。我希望你们知道如何坚持自己的立场，对自己的身份和行为诚实。我觉得我做到了这一点。法庭做到了这一点。它教会了你们对彼此的忠诚，教会了你们不互相告发的事实，而且你们至今仍不告发对方。
Well, Sean did.
嗯，肖恩做过。
That's who she was. She did. She told everything.
那就是她的本色。她确实做过。她把一切都说了。
Talking to her, I realized that Harriot Court was not some genius institution that fit perfectly into my mom's master plan. Like most parents, she was just making it up as she went along. But to us, my mom tried this amazingly ambitious thing. Because of it, we still have this almost unreasonable faith in logic and justice. And whenever we talk, our conversations end the exact same way my mom ended each session of Harriot Court-- OK, make good choices.
和她交谈后，我意识到哈里奥特法庭并不是什么天才式的机构，完美契合我妈的宏伟蓝图。像大多数家长一样，她只是边走边摸索。但对我们来说，我妈尝试了这种令人惊叹的雄心壮志。因为这件事，我们至今对逻辑和正义仍抱有一种近乎不合理的信念。每当我们交谈时，我们的对话总是以我妈结束哈里奥特法庭每一场审判的相同方式告终——好了，做出好的选择。
Michael Harriot, he's a writer for The Grio. His latest book is Black AF History, The Un-Whitewashed Story of America. His story was produced by Emmanuel Dzotsi. Coming up, a thief steals something very rare to build a spaceship. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
迈克尔·哈里奥特，他是《The Grio》网站的撰稿人。他最新的书是《Black AF History, The Un-Whitewashed Story of America》。他的故事由伊曼纽尔·佐齐制作。稍后，一个小偷为了建造宇宙飞船偷走了一些非常罕见的东西。那将在稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，稍后节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Minor Crimes Division, stories of tiny acts of wrongdoing, what they say about the people who commit them and about the people who've devoted themselves to catching and punishing these acts.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“轻微罪行部门”，讲述微小的违规行为，关于这些行为揭示了做这些事的人以及那些致力于抓捕和惩罚这些行为的人。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Alternate Side." Well, sometimes, there's a disagreement over whether a tiny act of wrongdoing is, in fact, an act of wrongdoing at all. One of our producers, Aviva DeKornfeld, has such a tale.
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“候补车位”。嗯，有时人们会产生分歧，关于一个小小的违规行为到底算不算违规。我们的制作人之一，阿维瓦·德科恩费尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld），就有这样一个故事。
Caveh Zahedi had just moved to San Francisco. He hadn't even really moved there yet. He'd just driven there with a car full of stuff and crashed at a friend's house while he looked for an apartment. He didn't have a permit to park in his friend's neighborhood, which meant he had to move his car every two hours.
卡维·扎赫迪（Caveh Zahedi）刚搬到旧金山。他甚至还没真正搬过来。他只是开着一辆装满东西的车，寄宿在朋友家，同时寻找公寓。他在朋友所在的街区没有停车证，这意味着他每两个小时就得挪一次车。
So, I would have to go every day, every two hours, and move the car.
所以，我每天必须每隔两小时去移动车辆。
He does this all day, every day. It's extremely annoying, but he's diligent about it. And then one day, he comes out to find a parking ticket tucked under his windshield wiper.
他没日没夜地做这件事。这极其烦人，但他很勤勉。然后有一天，他出来时发现雨刷下塞着一张停车罚单。
I remember I was like, what the fuck? I moved it. It's been less than two hours. This is wrong. I didn't do anything wrong. I followed the rules.
我记得我当时就想，这他妈是怎么回事？我挪了啊。还没到两小时。这不对。我没做错任何事。我遵守了规则。
It was an expensive ticket, around $300. He decides to contest it.
那是一张昂贵的罚单，大约300美元。他决定提出异议。
So I go to the court, and I explain to the judge what happened. And she says, how far did you move it? And I said, I don't know. Maybe like 30 feet? Just guessing. I didn't even know what 30 feet looked like. And I said, why? How far are you supposed to move it?
所以我去了法庭，向法官解释了发生了什么。她说，你挪了多远？我说，我不知道。大概30英尺（约9米）？就猜的。我甚至不知道30英尺看起来有多长。我说，为什么？你应该挪多远？
She says, I don't know. Let me look it up. So she takes out this big law book. And she's going through it, and she finds a thing. She says, oh, here it is. It says here, you have to move it, oh, 35 feet, so I'm afraid I have to give you the ticket. You lose.
她说，我不知道。让我查查。于是她拿出这本厚厚的法律书。她翻阅着，找到了一个条款。她说，哦，在这儿。上面写着，你必须挪动哦，35英尺，所以我恐怕不得不给你这张罚单。你败诉了。
And I said, wait a minute. First of all, it might have been 35. It might have been 40. I don't know. I didn't measure it. Second of all, you didn't even know what the amount was. And if you don't even know what the amount was, why should I have to pay a ticket for something that you don't even know what the law is? No one knows. They didn't say anything about it. It's in this stupid book, and it's ridiculous. She said, well, I'm sorry. Ignorance of the law is no excuse.
我说，等等。首先，可能挪了35英尺。也可能是40英尺。我不知道。我没量过。其次，你连（挪动距离）标准是多少都不知道。既然你连标准是多少都不知道，我为什么要为你们自己连法律规定都不清楚的事情交罚单呢？没人知道。他们什么都没说。这写在这一本愚蠢的书里，这太荒谬了。她说，嗯，很抱歉。不知法不免罪。
Caveh was upset. He turned to leave.
卡维很心烦。他转身想走。
And I just couldn't accept defeat like that without saying anything. I wanted her to feel at least bad about it, or at least, I just wanted to put some doubt in her mind that she may have been wrong.
我实在无法不发一言就接受这种失败。我希望她至少能为此感到愧疚，或者至少，我只是想在她脑子里种下一颗怀疑的种子，怀疑她可能错了。
This is the kind of person Caveh is. When he sees something in the world that seems wrong or ill-conceived or unfair, it's very hard for him not to point it out. This is either a strength or a personality defect. He sees it as both.
卡维就是这种人。当他看到世界上某种看起来是错的、考虑不周或者不公平的事情时，他很难不去指出来。这既是优点也是人格缺陷。他觉得两者皆有。
Caveh majored in philosophy-- still reads it sometimes-- which is why, on his way out of the courtroom, he stopped, turned back to the judge, and-- I know how this sounds-- said this, do you know the distinction between legalism and essentialism in Chinese philosophy? No surprise, the judge said, no, she didn't.
卡维主修哲学——至今偶尔还在读——这就是为什么在走出法庭时，他停下来，转身面对法官，说出了这一句——我知道听起来很怪——你知道中国哲学中法家和本真论的区分吗？不出所料，法官说，不，她不知道。
And I said, well, the legalists believe in applying the letter of the law, and the essentialists believe in the spirit of the law. And in terms of the spirit of the law, I didn't do anything wrong. I followed the spirit of the law, the spirit of the law to get you to move your car so other people can use that spot, and you don't just hog it. I did that.
我说，嗯，法家相信应用法律条文，而本真论者相信法律的精神。就法律的精神而言，我没做错任何事。我遵循了法律精神，法律精神是让你移动车辆以便其他人可以使用该车位，你不会垄断它。我做到了。
The letter of the law says 35 feet, but it's random and arbitrary. It could be 34 feet or 36 feet or 40 feet or 20 feet. It doesn't really matter. It's just like this literal nonsense. And the essentialists are right, and the legalists are wrong. And you are aligning with the legalists. And she said something like, well, that's very interesting. Thank you for enlightening me.
法律条文说35英尺，但那是随意且武断的。它可以是34英尺、36英尺、40英尺或20英尺。那其实并不重要。这就像某种字面意义上的废话。本真论者是对的，法家是错的。而你站在法家那边。她说，嗯，这非常有趣。谢谢你的开导。
Did you think that would work?
你觉得那会有用吗？
I always think that people can be persuaded of something that makes sense.
我总觉得人们是可以被有道理的事情说服的。
But if I'm a judge and some guy starts talking to me about the nuances in Chinese philosophy, I feel like I'd be like, I'm going to double that guy's fine.
但如果我是法官，某个家伙开始跟我谈论中国哲学中的细微差别，我觉得我会说，我要把那家伙的罚款翻倍。
[LAUGHS] Well, she didn't double it, but she certainly didn't cancel it.
（笑）好吧，她没翻倍，但肯定没撤销。
You still had to pay.
你还是得交。
Yeah, yeah, I paid.
是啊，是啊，我交了。
This all happened years ago. It turns out the fine Caveh had to pay was smaller than he remembers, and the number of feet for parking was larger, but the spirit of the story remains the same. Anyway, Caveh finally gets an apartment of his own and a parking permit for his car, so he doesn't have to move it every two hours anymore. But it's still hard to find a place to park.
这一切发生在多年前。事实证明，卡维支付的罚款比他记忆中的要少，而停车所需的英尺数要更多，但故事的精神是一样的。不管怎样，卡维最终有了自己的公寓和停车证，所以他不必再每两小时挪车了。但想找个地方停车还是很难。
And sometimes you are just circling the streets, like, for half an hour or an hour, and it's late at night. And you can't find a spot, and you're tired, and you're angry, and you're hungry. And you're just like, ugh!
有时你只是在街上绕圈，就像，绕了半小时或一小时，已经是深夜了。你找不到车位，你很累，很生气，而且很饿。你只会想，啊！
And so, sometimes, you're just desperate, so you'll park somewhere that's kind of like borderline illegal. So I did that. I couldn't take it anymore, so I just parked near the corner curb, which you're not supposed to. And but it was barely touching. It was barely. And the next morning, I go to my car, and I have a ticket. And I decided to contest it.
所以，有时，你只是太绝望了，所以你会停在某种接近违规的地方。于是我那么做了。我实在受不了了，所以我就停在角落的路缘附近，你是不应该停那儿的。但它只是擦到一点。就一点点。第二天早上，我去开车，我收到了罚单。我决定提出异议。
And why? You actually did something wrong this time.
为什么？这一次你确实做错了什么。
I know, but it was so much money, and it was so close. I don't. I just-- I contested it.
我知道，但这罚款太多钱了，而且违规程度太轻微了。我不知道。我只是……我还是异议了。
What were you imagining your argument would be? Because you can't do the spirit of the law, letter of the law thing in this case.
你想象中的论点是什么？因为在这种情况下你不能再用什么法律精神、法律条文那一套了。
I don't know what I was thinking. I thought maybe-- I don't know. It makes no sense, but I contested it. And I go to the same court. I wait around for a long time, and I get the same judge. And she says to me, I remember you. You're the guy [LAUGHS] who talked to me about the difference between legalism and essentialism in Chinese philosophy. And I said, yeah, you remember that? And she's like, I do. She says, I thought about that a lot.
我不知道当时在想什么。我想也许……我不知道。这说不通，但我还是异议了。我去了同一个法庭。我等了很久，又遇到了同一个法官。她对我说，我记得你。你就是那个（笑）跟我谈论中国哲学中法家与本真论区别的家伙。我说，是啊，你还记得？她说，我记得。她说，我仔细思考了那件事。
She said, and thinking about it, I think you were right. I think the spirit of the law is more important than the letter of the law. And I regretted giving you that ticket. And even though you are clearly guilty in this case, I'm not going to make you pay for this ticket because I made you pay for one that you weren't guilty for. So she canceled it.
她说，思考之后，我觉得你是对的。我认为法律精神确实比法律条文更重要。我后悔给你开那张罚单了。尽管这次你确实明显违规了，但我不会让你交这张罚单，因为我之前让你交了一张你并不该交的罚单。于是她撤销了。
That's unbelievable.
太不可思议了。
That a person could be persuaded by another person?
一个人能被另一个人说服？
Kind of. How often do people change their minds? Almost never.
有点。人们多久会改变主意一次？几乎从不。
Yeah, that's true. That's sad.
是的，那确实。那很可悲。
What was your reaction?
你的反应是什么？
Well, I was delighted. [LAUGHS] And I don't know. I felt like the world seems so inhuman and so bureaucratic, and it just seemed like the human had prevailed for once.
嗯，我很高兴。（笑）我不知道。我觉得这个世界看起来太没有人情味，太官僚了，而这一次看起来人性终于战胜了机制。
Seriously, all across the world, on any given day, how many people actually take the time to listen to what a complete stranger has to say, consider it, change their mind, and then admit to it? Hardly ever. And the fact that this doesn't happen more often, that's a crime, and not a minor one.
说真的，全世界范围内，在任何一天，有多少人真正花时间去倾听一个完全陌生人要说的话，仔细考虑它，改变主意，然后承认这一点？几乎没有。而这种情况之所以不常发生，那才是一种罪，而且不是轻微的罪。
Aviva DeKornfeld. Caveh Zahedi told this story on his podcast, 365 Stories I Want to Tell You Before We Both Die.
阿维瓦·德科恩费尔德。卡维·扎赫迪在他的播客《365 Stories I Want to Tell You Before We Both Die》中讲述了这个故事。
Act Three, "Jewel Intentions." So sometimes small crimes can be hard to solve because they are so small. This next story is about a scheme that had been going on for a very long time, right under everybody's noses. It was brazen, but nobody could figure out who was behind it. Micaela Blei told the story of what happened on stage at The Moth.
第三幕，“珠宝意图”。有时小罪行很难解决，因为它们太微小了。下一个故事是关于一个一直在进行且持续了很长时间的诡计，就在每个人眼皮底下。它很猖狂，但没人能查出幕后黑手是谁。米凯拉·布莱（Micaela Blei）在The Moth舞台上讲述了这件事。
In the elementary school where I teach, there are LEGOs that are very valuable and LEGOs no one gives a shit about.
在我任教的小学里，有些乐高积木非常有价值，有些则根本没人关心。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
The ones you don't really care about are the ones there are thousands of-- the gray two by fours, the black two by fours, anything that's red. For some reason, all we have are red LEGOs. And the ones that are valuable are the things that you can't really find.
那些你不太在意的，是那些成千上万的——灰色的2x4积木、黑色的2x4积木、任何红色的东西。出于某种原因，我们有的全是红色乐高。而有价值的是那些你根本找不到的东西。
So there's a second grade, a third grade, and a fourth grade. Everyone's got bins. And in these bins, the things you very rarely see are anything lime green. I think once upon a time, we had a set that was lime green. Anything that has a picture on it, it's kind of magical. And then these jewels. There are these little, plastic, clear-colored LEGOs, and they really look valuable. And I mean, I'm kind of psyched about them, too.
所以，有二年级、三年级和四年级。每个人都有储物箱。而在这些箱子里，你很少见到的东西就是任何酸橙绿色的积木。我想曾几何时，我们有一套酸橙绿色的。任何带图片的零件，都显得很神奇。然后就是这些珠宝。它们是这些小小的、塑料的、透明颜色的乐高零件，它们看起来真的非常有价值。而且我是说，我自己也被它们深深吸引了。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And every class has, especially my class, has what I like to call the "black hole boys." They are the boys who sit anytime there's choice time and put together LEGOs and discuss theories of outer space and infinity. And they build spaceships, and they're like, well, OK, but could there be a black hole that would be strong enough to pull other black holes in? And they all think about that for a while. And they're my boys. I like them. I'm really into them.
每个班都有，尤其是我的班，有我称之为“黑洞男孩”的一群人。他们是那种只要有自由活动时间就坐在一起拼乐高、讨论外太空和无限大理论的男孩。他们建造宇宙飞船，他们会说，好吧，那有没有一种黑洞能强大到把其他黑洞吸进去？他们都会思考这个问题一会儿。他们就是我的男孩。我喜欢他们。我非常迷他们。
And most of playing LEGOs in anywhere in my school is really mostly just pawing through, looking for the valuable ones. I mean, of course, you could build with them, but that's not the fun part. The fun part is, I found this orange jewel, or whatever. So that's always a big deal, and all the bins are outside, underneath the cubbies. So every class has their bins near their class's cubbies.
而且在学校任何地方玩乐高，大部分时间其实都只是在翻找，寻找那些有价值的。当然，你也可以用它们建造东西，但那不是乐趣所在。真正的乐趣在于，我找到了这个橙色的珠宝，或者之类的。所以那总是一件大事，所有的箱子都放在柜子下面。每个班的箱子都在他们班储物柜附近。
I teach third grade. The second graders come to me one day, and they say, we need your help. We think someone's been stealing our jewels. Now, they have to dismantle all their LEGOs at the end of every week so that it's really fair, so you have a chance to paw through and find the jewels anew every Monday. And they have been noticing that over the course of several weeks, they find fewer and fewer jewels, and they suspect my class.
我教三年级。二年级的孩子们有一天来找我，说，我们需要你的帮助。我们认为有人一直在偷我们的珠宝。因为规定是每周结束时必须拆掉所有乐高作品，这样才公平，让你每周一都有机会翻找并寻找新的珠宝。他们注意到在过去几周里，珠宝越来越少，他们怀疑是我班上的孩子。
And I say, you know what? That's not really fair. I'm sure that it is not my guys who are doing that. And they say, well, we think you should look through their bins, at their spaceships, and find out if they have got our jewels.
我说，你知道吗？那不公平。我肯定不是我的孩子们干的。他们说，嗯，我们认为你应该检查一下他们的箱子，他们的宇宙飞船，看看他们有没有拿走我们的珠宝。
And I said, you know what? That's not what we're going to do. We're going to trust them. We're going to ask them, did you take those jewels? And if they say no, we're going to believe them. Because secretly, I'm thinking, A, there's no way my boys did it, and B, I don't really want to get in the middle of that if that's what's going on.
我说，你知道吗？那不是我们要做的。我们要信任他们。我们要问他们，你们拿了那些珠宝吗？如果他们说没有，我们就相信他们。因为我暗中想，第一，我的孩子绝对不可能干那种事；第二，如果真是那样，我也不想卷入其中。
So we asked my boys. And the sort of ringleader, the head of the black hole boys, Edward is this very smart, very sour kid whose spaceships are amazing. I mean, they look like they could really go. And he says, no, we have not. Have you tried the fourth grade? Because those guys think they're so big.
所以我们问了我的孩子们。领头人，黑洞男孩们的头目，爱德华是一个非常聪明但性格有点酸溜溜的孩子，他拼的宇宙飞船非常棒。我是说，看起来它们真的能飞一样。他说，没有，我们没拿。你们试过四年级了吗？因为那帮家伙觉得自己很了不起。
And so me and these three little second graders go to the fourth grade. And we say to some of the fourth graders who are playing with LEGOs, Did you guys take these jewels? And the fourth graders say no, and then later, privately, they say, Are you sure the second graders are telling the truth? Because they think they're so cute.
于是我和这三个二年级的小朋友去了四年级班。我们对几个正在玩乐高的四年级学生说，你们拿了这些珠宝吗？四年级学生说没有，然后私下里他们说，你们确定二年级那些小鬼说的是真话吗？因为他们觉得那帮小孩特别爱装可爱。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
There's a culture of fear developing across all three grades. No one trusts each other. Everyone's sort of looking at each other's things that they're building. And the teachers are picking up on it, too. I'm sort of watching everyone's spaceships, being like, I don't remember that orange one and that green one and the blue one in the second grade of 2A. I don't know if that's right.
在三个年级之间蔓延着一种恐惧文化。没人信任对方。每个人都在打量别人正在建的东西。老师们也察觉到了。我一直在观察每个人的宇宙飞船，心想，我不记得2A班的二年级箱子里有那个橙色的、绿色的和蓝色的零件。我不知道那是否对劲。
And I'm sort of getting there, too, but we're all kind of watching each other. And then I am getting homework. Edward does his homework and does more homework than he needs to, but he always forgets to hand it in. And so I just randomly-- I go into his cubby just to grab the math homework that I know is in there. Under the math homework is a jewel encrusted spaceship.
我也快要查到了，但大家都在互相盯着。然后我布置了作业。爱德华做完了作业，甚至比要求的还多，但他总是忘记交。所以我只是随意地……我走进他的储物柜，只是为了去拿我知道在那里的数学作业。在数学作业下面是一个镶满珠宝的宇宙飞船。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Dazzling. The wings have wings, and those wings have other things. And there's a glass window that I have literally never seen before. In the six years that I've been teaching there, I have never seen this glass window. It's beautiful, but I'm stuck with a dilemma. What do I do with this? If I accuse him, then number one, the second graders are kind of intense, and I'm a little worried about what they would do.
炫目。翅膀上还有翅膀，那些翅膀上还有其他东西。还有一个玻璃窗，我真的从来没见过。我在那里教书的六年里，从来没见过这个玻璃窗。它很漂亮，但我陷入了困境。我该怎么处理它？如果我指责他，第一，二年级的孩子们有点较真，我很担心他们会做出什么过激行为。
Number two, I already told the second graders it couldn't have possibly been my boys. This is my reputation on the line as well. I don't want it to have been him. I could, it occurs to me, just steal it back. I could just take it. Because if he tried to say someone stole my jewel encrusted spaceship, that would be on him. That would be his-- that's a dilemma he would have.
第二，我已经告诉二年级学生，绝对不可能是我班上的孩子干的。这也是我的声誉问题。我不希望真的是他。我心想，我可以……直接把它偷回来。我可以直接拿走。因为如果他想说有人偷了他的镶满珠宝的宇宙飞船，那得由他承担。那是他要面对的困境。
But then I realized that that could possibly be framing another kid, and I do have-- I have my line I will not cross. So I'm not going to frame a kid. So instead, I wait for a Friday, when we should be taking apart our things. And he has not been taking apart this spaceship.
但我意识到那样做可能会陷害另一个孩子，而我……我有我的底线。所以我不打算陷害孩子。所以我等到周五，我们本该拆掉作品的时候。他一直没有拆掉这个飞船。
And I wait till Friday. I get him alone, and I say to him really casually, so don't forget to take apart your spaceship. And he looks at me, and he knows I know. And he says something really ballsy. He goes, I did. I already did.
我一直等到周五。我把他单独叫过来，非常随意地对他说，嘿，别忘了拆掉你的飞船。他看着我，他知道我知道。他说了句非常有胆识的话。他说，我拆了。我早就拆了。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I sit down with him. I open the cubby. I show him the spaceship. And I say, this is an amazing spaceship. You did a really great job. But you got to let it go. And we cut a deal. And over the course of several weeks, we dismantle the spaceship very, very slowly. I can't just smash it. I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to just take the whole thing apart.
我和他坐下来。我打开储物柜。我给他看了那个飞船。我说，这是一个非常棒的飞船。你做得真的很棒。但你得放下它。我们达成了一个协议。在接下来的几周里，我们非常、非常缓慢地拆卸了这个飞船。我不能直接砸碎它。我不会那样做。我不会就那样把它全拆了。
And I start secretly putting those jewels back in other people's cubbies for him, so that he can still be the head of the black hole boys and not lose that reputation that he has that he loves, and so that I don't have to go back on my word that my boys didn't do anything. I was an accessory to a third grade crime. There's no way around that. That's it. Thank you.
然后我开始暗中把那些珠宝放回其他人的储物柜里，这样他仍然可以是黑洞男孩的领头人，不会失去他心爱的那个名声，而且我也不用食言说我的孩子们没干过坏事。我成了三年级犯罪的共犯。没法绕开这一点。就是这样。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Micaela Blei lives in Portland, Maine.
米凯拉·布莱住在缅甸波特兰。
Act Four, "Occam's Toilet." OK, so earlier in our show, we had a mom who invented an entire courtroom to teach her kids some lessons and some values. In this act, we have parents doing something so much simpler. They're simply trying to level with their kids and reason with them, together. And in this case, they recorded what happened. We've actually changed everybody's names at the kids' request. Bethel Habte tells the story.
第四幕，“奥卡姆的马桶”。好了，在节目早些时候，我们有一位发明了整个法庭来教孩子功课和价值观的母亲。在这一幕里，我们有做着更简单事情的父母。他们只是试着和孩子们平起平坐，理智地沟通。在这种情况下，他们录下了发生的事情。应孩子们的要求，我们更改了所有人的名字。贝瑟尔·哈布特（Bethel Habte）讲述了这个故事。
Todd and Amy live in a house in New Jersey. It's an old house. And one day, they noticed they've got a plumbing problem. There's liquid pooling in this hole in their basement floor around a sewage pipe. They call a plumber, who snakes the drain and charges them $500. And then, a few weeks later, the liquid reappears.
托德和艾米住在新泽西州的一栋房子里。那是一栋老房子。有一天，他们注意到水管出了问题。地下室地板上的一个污水管周围的地洞里有液体聚集。他们找了一个管道工，管道工疏通了管道并收了他们500美元。然后，几周后，液体又出现了。
A second plumber comes in. He can't find any other problems with their sewage system. His professional opinion is that there isn't anything wrong with their sewage system. He thinks what's going on is much simpler. The liquid in the hole is actually pee. Someone in their house is peeing in the hole.
第二个管道工来了。他没法在污水系统中发现任何其他问题。他的专业意见是污水系统没有任何问题。他认为发生的事情要简单得多。地洞里的液体实际上是尿液。有人在家里往那个洞里尿尿。
What the plumber suggested seemed entirely possible. Amy and Todd have three boys, eight-year-old twins, Ryan and Lawrence, and their younger brother, Hugh. He's six. And so they gather the kids together to find out who peed in the hole. Amy, their mom, records a video of the meeting on her phone.
管道工的建议听起来完全可能。艾米和托德有三个儿子，八岁的双胞胎瑞安和劳伦斯，以及他们的弟弟休（Hugh）。他六岁。于是他们把孩子们聚在一起，查出是谁在地洞里撒尿。艾米的妈妈在手机上录下了这次谈话的视频。
We had the plumber come again. And two times in just over three weeks, there's been urine backed up in the basement, like pee. Now--
管道工又来了。在三周多一点的时间里，地下室两次出现了积压的尿液，就像尿一样。现在……
In the basement floor?
在地下室地板上？
That's Ryan, twin number one. They're all sitting on a navy blue sectional. Todd keeps calmly laying out the facts. Yes, they think there's pee on the basement floor.
那是瑞安，双胞胎之一。他们都坐在深蓝色的沙发上。托德冷静地陈述着事实。是的，他们认为地下室地板上有尿。
Yeah, in that little recess. In that little hole in the floor.
是的，在那个小凹槽里。地板上的那个小洞里。
Who's peeing in the hole in the floor?
是谁往地板洞里撒尿的？
Not me.
不是我。
The one who just said "not me," that's Hugh, the little one. Lawrence, twin number two, hasn't said anything yet. He's quiet, with a blank expression on his face. Then Ryan asks a question.
刚才说“不是我”的那个，是休，最小的孩子。劳伦斯，双胞胎之二，还没说话。他很安静，脸上没有任何表情。然后瑞安问了一个问题。
Can I just say something?
我能说件事吗？
Yes.
可以。
Whenever Macey pees indoors, she always does it in the basement.
每当梅西（宠物狗）在室内撒尿时，她总是在地下室。
He wants to know if it's possible that the dog did it.
他想知道有没有可能是狗干的。
So it is entirely possible. My question to any of you is, have any of you ever gone and just peed in that hole in the basement?
所以这完全有可能。我问你们任何人的问题是，你们有没有人直接往地下室的那个洞里撒过尿？
No.
没有。
No! That's disgusting!
没有！那太恶心了！
Ew.
额。
Do you swear?
你们发誓吗？
Yes! Yes!
是的！是的！
I promise.
我发誓。
Because here's the thing--
因为重点是……
That "I promise" there, that's Lawrence, the quiet twin. He breaks his silence. So now, all three children have denied peeing in the hole. Their dad tries to explain to the kids, someone peeing in the hole is actually the best possible scenario.
那个“我发誓”，是劳伦斯，安静的双胞胎。他打破了沉默。所以现在，三个孩子都否认往洞里撒尿。他们的爸爸试着向孩子们解释，往洞里撒尿其实是最好的结果。
It would not be good and I would not be happy, but it would be preferable that if someone is doing this, that you're honest because the other explanation is that we have a bad sewage problem that no one can explain. So it's actually better if someone just says, yes, it was me. It was an accident. I did it twice. Because then, at least, we're not crazy, and we don't have to have a plumber come again--
那并不好，我也不会高兴，但如果一定要有人干这事，我希望你们诚实，因为另一种解释是我们有一个没人能解释的严重污水问题。所以如果有人承认说，是的，是我。是一场意外。我干了两次。那样其实更好。因为至少，我们没疯，我们也不用再找管道工来了……
Yeah, because we already spent a lot of money trying to figure out what's going on.
是的，因为我们已经花了很多钱试图查明到底是怎么回事。
--trying to figure out what's going on here.
……试图查明到底是怎么回事。
It was me.
是我。
It was me, Ryan says. But then, it turns out, he was just trying to get the interrogation over with.
“是我”，瑞安说。但后来发现，他只是想让审问快点结束。
Wait, I didn't pee in there, but can I just say that?
等等，我没往那里面撒尿，但我能那样说吗？
No, that doesn't help. If you're lying, that doesn't help.
不，那没用。如果你撒谎，那没用。
We just want you guys to be honest, OK? Just tell us.
我们只是想让你们诚实，好吗？只要告诉我们。
I am being honest. I never--
我很诚实。我从来没……
I am.
我是。
OK, let's go one by one.
好，我们一个一个来。
They ask every child again, starting with twin number one, Ryan.
他们再次询问了每个孩子，从双胞胎之一的瑞安开始。
Have you peed--
你有撒尿……
Did you honestly-- have you ever peed--
你诚实地……你有没有撒过尿……
--in that space?
……在那个空间里？
--in that hole?
……在那个洞里？
OK, and here's another question.
好，这是另一个问题。
When I was really little, I maybe--
当我还是很小的时候，我可能……
We're talking about now.
我们说的是现在。
We're talking-- there was this weekend and three weeks ago.
我们在说……上周末和三周前。
No, I never peed in it.
没有，我从来没往那里面撒过尿。
OK, did you see anybody of your brothers do it?
好，你有没有见过你的兄弟们任何一个那样做？
I never saw anybody pee in it.
我从来没见过任何人往里面撒尿。
OK, next.
好，下一个。
Next, Hugh, the youngest. He's been fidgeting with a rainbow bookmark, fanning himself with it.
下一个，休，最小的。他一直在玩一个彩虹书签，用它给自己扇风。
It was not me.
不是我。
No, no.
没有，没有。
Did you see anybody do it?
你有没有见过任何人那样做？
I swear. No.
我发誓。没有。
And you didn't do it?
而且你没做？
Yes.
是的。
You swear?
你发誓？
Yes.
是的。
Finally, Lawrence, twin number two. He answers the question with the directness of a politician caught up in a scandal.
最后，劳伦斯，双胞胎之二。他回答问题的直接程度堪比陷入丑闻的政客。
I did not pee in the hole.
我没往洞里撒尿。
OK.
好。
[GIGGLING]
（咯咯笑）
OK, the next thing we're going to have is, we're going to go down to the police department because they have a lie detector test.
好，接下来的事，我们要去警察局了，因为他们有测谎仪。
OK.
好。
That sounds fun.
那听起来很有趣。
Everyone's good?
大家都好了吗？
The twins, Ryan and Lawrence, are in, but Hugh, the little one, lets out a nervous giggle.
双胞胎瑞安和劳伦斯都答应了，但休，那个小的，发出了一声紧张的咯咯笑。
[GIGGLE]
（咯咯笑）
So before we go to the police department, can anyone just tell the truth?
所以，在我们去警察局之前，有人愿意说真话吗？
Fine!
好吧！
Hugh shoots his hand in the air. His eyes are wide, and he's smiling.
休把手举向空中。他眼睛睁得很大，微笑着。
Yeah.
是的。
It was you?
是你？
Did you do it?
是你干的吗？
Wait, really?
等等，真的吗？
[LAUGHS] Yes. Yes, I swear.
（笑）是的。是的，我发誓。
Are you telling the truth?
你在说实话吗？
Yes, I actually did.
是的，我真的干了。
Did you actually pee?
你真的撒尿了？
Yes, I did. I did.
是的，我撒了。我撒了。
How many times?
多少次？
Once. That's only--
一次。那只是……
How many times?
多少次？
Only once.
只有一次。
Because somebody-- it had to--
因为有人……必须……
It happened twice.
发生了两次。
It had to have happened more than one time.
一定不止一次。
OK, then I probably did it, like, three times.
好，那我也许做了，大概三次。
All right, why?
好吧，为什么？
I don't know. Because I needed to go so bad. And one time, I need to go so bad--
我不知道。因为我憋得太难受了。有一次，我憋得实在太难受了……
Well, why didn't you just go to the bathroom?
好吧，为什么不直接去洗手间？
Because I was like so far away from the bathroom and--
因为我离洗手间太远了……
Listeners, there is a bathroom in the basement. There are 25 steps that separate the bathroom from the play area, maybe a few more if your legs are short.
听众们，地下室里有个洗手间。洗手间和游戏区之间隔着25级台阶，如果你的腿短点可能还要多走几步。
How many times did you do it again?
你再说一遍你做了多少次？
So you peed down that hole--
所以你往那个洞里撒尿……
Three times.
三次。
--in the basement?
……在地下室？
Are you crying?
你在哭吗？
Oh, God. A little bit.
哦，天哪。有一点。
We're taking $500 out of your bank account.
我们要从你的银行账户里扣除500美元。
Well, I don't even have any.
可是我根本没有钱。
Then you're going to have zero money.
那你就剩零钱了。
Just forget it, OK?
算了，好吗？
Case closed. Court adjourned. Hugh's mom told me the point of this whole thing was, yes, to solve the crime, but also to bring these kids into the adult world for just a moment, see the situation the way they do. But she knows it was probably too much to ask. Kids live in their own world. It's a world without plumbers who charge $500. It's a world where a hole in the ground looks like a perfectly good place to pee.
结案。休庭。休的妈妈告诉我，整个这件事的重点是，没错，为了破案，但也为了让这些孩子们在这一刻进入成人的世界，看看他们眼中的情况。但她知道这可能要求太高了。孩子们生活在他们自己的世界里。那是一个没有收取500美元费用的管道工的世界。那是一个地上的洞看起来是个完美的撒尿之处的世界。
Bethel Habte is an editor at our show.
贝瑟尔·哈布特是我们节目的编辑。
Well, today's program was produced by Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Phia Benin, Jendayi Bonds, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Chana Joffe-Walt, Rudy Lee, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Safiyah Riddle, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
好了，今天的节目由阿维瓦·德科恩费尔德制作。今天节目组成员包括Bim Adewunmi、Phia Benin、Jendayi Bonds、Zoe Chace、Sean Cole、Michael Comite、Chana Joffe-Walt、Rudy Lee、Katherine Rae Mondo、Nadia Reiman、Safiyah Riddle、Ryan Rumery、Frances Swanson、Christopher Swetala、Matt Tierney、Julie Whitaker和Diane Wu。我们的总编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的资深编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。
Special thanks today to Kate Emmerich, Penelope SS Wong, Jaki Reis, Noah Lanard, Alexi Horowitz-Ghazi, Jameka Brown, and Cathleen Conte. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite shows if you're looking for something to listen to. Lots of other stuff there. Anyway, thisamericanlife.org.
今天特别鸣谢Kate Emmerich、Penelope SS Wong、Jaki Reis、Noah Lanard、Alexi Horowitz-Ghazi、Jameka Brown和Cathleen Conte。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体收听我们超过800集的档案。还有视频。如果你正在寻找可以听的东西，还有精选节目列表。上面还有很多其他东西。总之，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he went on trial this week for stealing 15 pairs of shoes. His defense, I got to say, was not the strongest.
《美国生活》通过PRX（公共广播交易所）向公共广播电台发送。一如既往，感谢我们节目的创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道吗，他这周因为偷了15双鞋而受审。不得不说，他的辩护，并不是最强的。
I didn't even know what 30 feet looked like.
我甚至不知道30英尺看起来有多长。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
["CRIMINAL MISCHIEF (FOR ADAM WHITE)" BY JIMMY AND THE JAYWALKERS]
["刑事毁坏（致亚当·怀特）" —— 吉米和乱穿马路者乐队]